Joshua is with us in Nevada hi Joshua
how are you yeah how are you doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up
okay so last year I bought a car and I
flipped over some negative value and I
find I was $30,000 and now I'm about
almost $15,000 upside down on the car
which I for the car I paid twenty two
thousand for the car we're done seven
thousand dollars in one year i well i
financed thirty because I had no I got
that part you said you're fifteen
thousand and the whole you paid twenty
two that means the car is worth fifteen
now yeah exactly went down seven
thousand dollars in one year I've had
terrible luck with this car I've had
like three people analyze it so I got
damages on the car that I didn't repair
so that's adding to the you know I have
insurance to devalue my law I do
I needed that car fixed it just doesn't
make sense to me because my deductible
is a thousand dollars so I mean the
damage is you know if each one I set up
a claim for each one it's you know I
could just pay out of pocket and it's
probably less in probably like $800
fixes okay so I don't holler fixes and
then what's the car worth at best
seventeen eighteen thousand okay so your
5k in the show so your thirteen thousand
dollars in the home
good lord what do you make I make my
wife combined income is six thousand but
I use the car for uber I'm terrible with
that it's about seventy four hundred so
my question was should I sell it and get
a beater to uh I'm you know just a
swallow I guess or deal with whatever I
have or keep the car and keep the extra
income so you're making how much on over
a month about a thousand okay you're
driving about three nights a week yeah
you're on drives on that much if you're
doing make an only make it a thousand
bucks no I'm not
yeah okay
you know five six nights a week could be
three or four thousand a month ya know I
don't do very much why do you do it yeah
I would sell it because you're not doing
this much well yeah it's not it's not
justifying it and you've got a mess on
your hands and yeah it just gets you a
beater and let's just work our way back
out of this you're gonna have to drop a
bomb on this because it's a mess and
that that's what you're facing that's if
you can get a loan to cover that
difference and you are deeply in the
hole to cover that difference